Guten morgen JS Conf EU
So today as an ?? said that I'm going
to talk about things that I think I know
what you're talking about but I'm not
quite sure so I'm Jenn I'm a front-end
developer I am currently a software or
software engineer at Eventbrite as an
extent and you may know me the creator
of human waste land also known as the
poop map particularly those view from
the bay area you may also know me as the
creator of developers developers which
is a project I recently created a
dedication to Mr Steve Ballmer but all
of that is just a long winded way of
saying that I write code for a living
before we get started them quick
disclaimers there are going to be a lot
of animated gifs in the talk and there
may be a few errors
if you notice any of those errors before
you start to feel a little bit like this
or a little bit like this
let's talk about it becoming finally
after I talk let's go as i said im a
developer software engineer programmer
or whatever else you might want to call
me so some days and I look at my
computer this is how I feel and I'm
pretty sure many of you can relate to
that feeling and sometimes when I'm in
conversation with other developers I
feel like this
so Phil Karlson once there are two of
only two hard things in computer science
cache invalidation and naming things and
we can see that in the many various
complicated terms in computer science
and web development so here is just a
general sampling of some of the words
I've come across in my career as a
programmer and oftentimes I hear them
and I'm like their little bit familiar I
think I know what you're talking about
but not really sure and so in those
conversations I often ask people can you
explain that word me and in doing so I
get a look like this
and when I get that looks from other
people it makes you feel like this again
these were the very complicated they
have very checkered past they have very
interesting history they come from all
different places and so today I'm gonna
go over a few of those terms so when you
hear them in conversation
perhaps you feel a little bit less like
this and you feel a little bit more like
this
right the first step is for a murder
versus argument what's the difference is
there 10 to find out I of course went to
Google and when i search parameter
argument you'll see many people are
wondering about the difference between
the two
because you can see it the third period
down that's auto fills so here I have
written a function it's called shark and
I call sharp at the very bottom with the
string left so how many people in the
audience think that the perimeter is
that first in that first line plot fired
raise your hand and how many people
think it is a string left in the bottom
line of this code raise your hand and
obviously everything and both times you
guys don't know
alright well I'm not going to tell you
but I'm going to keep going so forever
and online etymology dictionary and
etymology is essentially the history of
worth said that her amateur is a
measurable factor which helps to define
a particular system and when I read that
I'm like ok I think I know which one is
the primary now but I keep going and
when i search argument on the online
etymology dictionary I find that there's
just information about people arguing
with each other and Michael that doesn't
explain to you what an argument is so
you keep going and I check out computer
programming on Wikipedia and here I see
that the term parameter sometimes called
the formal parameter is often used to
refer to the variable as found in the
function definition
argument sometimes called the actual
parameter refers to the actual input
pass because I'm a developer this
definition makes sense to me but I
wonder why don't we stick with the terms
formal parameter and actual parameter
and find that out
we've gotta go down the rabbit hole so I
look at mathematics I've search
parameter an argument and mathematics on
Wikipedia and I find that a function
definition can also contain parameters
but unlike variables parameters are not
listed among the argument that the
function takes like what does that mean
Wikipedia like please go on so we hear
that the variable X designates the
functions argument but AV and he are the
parameters so I look at this quadratic
function and I see that x is the
argument and ab&c other parameters and
they wait wait a second so I have a math
function up on top and we see that aids
the parameter then I have a computer
science
for a function JavaScript and I see that
bars the parameter like whoa that's
totally messing me up right now so the
way I explained it is that this Bulldog
as a parameter computer science is the
football and so as soon as a programmer
computer science its definition just
gets foot completely on it
help define a function and arguments are
passed into a function but that's only
in computer science so here's our answer
the parameters up on top and shark in
the function definition and then the
argument is down at the bottom that
string left in the function call and all
that being said we just used for a
better argument interchangeably anyways
so that was easy right
alright next up is scope so I don't know
about all of you but when somebody asks
me to talk about scope I don't want to
talk about scope please don't make me
talk about go but I'm going to talk
about it today the first up is lexical
scoping and of course they go back to
Google and I see that lexical scoping
parentheses sometimes known as static
scoping is a convention used with many
programming languages that such the
scope or range of functionality of a
variable so that it may be only be
called for reference from within the
block of code in which it is defined
that definition has three different
equivalent definitions just within it so
they say that lexical scoping is
equivalent to static scoping scope is
related to or its equivalent to range of
functionality and called is equivalent
to reference were stopped what supports
the ball is actually used the term scope
in the definition of lexical scoping
study break it down a little bit in the
online etymology dictionary is a name
purpose object being aimed at mark or
target and I really explain it in
computer science 30 let's keep going to
search scope on Wikipedia and I feel
that a scope is a part of a program that
is or can be the scope for a set of
bindings a precise definition is tricky
see below
okay thanks alot Wikipedia I gotta see
below the pillow I see that in computer
programming the scope of a name by
ending an association of a name to an
entity such as a variable is the part of
a computer program where the binding is
valid
where the name can be used to refer to
the entity and Mike whoa that make sense
to me because I know what scope is
already but somebody who's new to
programming may come and read this and
be like I don't really know what youre
talking about and so when I read this
I'm like oh ok definition so you keep
going
same article on scope and Wikipedia and
then they say the strict definition of
lexical scope of a name or identifiers
is unambiguous thanks a lot Wikipedia
you're so condescending unambiguous but
it says that it is quote the portion of
source code in which a binding of a name
with an entity applies ok that makes
sense to me it's pretty short and sweet
and I keep reading and I see that it has
been virtually unchanged from its 1960
definition in the specification of algal
60 and I don't know about you all but
when I saw Algol 60 was like I don't
know what that is so I'll bill sixties
short for algorithmic language of 1960
and I'll go sixty was a first language
implementing nested function definitions
with lexical scope and I think wait so
we've had the definition of what local
scope since 1960 and it's still so hard
to explain to other people but
moving on let's talk about lexical vs
dynamics go to lexical scope is the main
focus of that Wikipedia article with
dynamic scope understood by contrast
with lexical scope sorry this and I'm
like really like I have to know what
lexical scope is first before you can
even define dynamics go for me
all right let's get a little bit deeper
the lexical on the online etymology
dictionary means pertaining to words
like ok what about dynamic and dynamic
means pertaining to force producing
motion or the opposite of static and I
was like oh that's pretty interesting
because I first definition of lexical
scoping on google said that lexical
scoping is also static scoping so you
keep going and look up more about scope
on Wikipedia again and for most
programming languages part of a program
refers to a portion of the source code
or area of texts and is known as lexical
scope oh ok that's where pretending the
words comes from and then in some
languages however part of a program
refers to the quote portion of run time
or time period during execution and
that's known as dynamic scope and then I
keep reading below and I see both of
these terms are somewhat misleading and
I keep reading they misused technical
terms as discussed in the definition or
so what I just read it wrong and then I
keep reading that says but the
distinction itself is accurate and
precise and these are the standard
respective terms like oh I thought I
just rode with right ok so I keep
reading again of course and we feel that
in practice with luck local scope of
variables definition is result by
searching its containing block or
function then if that fails searching
the outer containing block and so on
whereas with dynamic scope the calling
function as search then the function
which called that calling function and
so on and i go that's pretty clear I
think that makes sense to me so all that
being said this is a javascript
conference who cares about that
amex go the way I like to think about
lexical scope is the box as a function
the orange cat it's a variable in that
function
cat can see the white cat but the white
cat can see the orange cat
ok running back or to run back kind of
makes sense but not quite related to
computers so I look for corrosion on
Wikipedia and I read that the most
common application of recursion is in
mathematics and computer science in
which it refers to a method of defining
functions in which the function being
defined is applied within its own
definition wait I thought this was a
definition why is redefining so many
different definitions within its
definition so I keep reading and I think
that this is likely this defines an
infinite number of instances or function
values using a finite expression that
for some instances may refer to other
instances and in such a way that no lube
or infinite chain of references can
occur
let's keep going I keep reading down
this article and I see that in
mathematics and computer science class
of objects or method exhibit recursive
behavior when they can be defined by two
properties number one a simple base case
or cases it terminating scenario that
does not use recursion to produce an
answer and number two is that a rule
that reduce all of their cases toward
that base case and again kinda makes
sense to me because I am a developer
before somebody who's new they probably
are gonna give me a look like this when
they read that so at a pace I like to
describe recursion a function that calls
itself that's what I would like to see
on Wikipedia so often times he will
explain recursion to other people by
saying this and then they decide to get
a little bit more complicated and talk
about the Fibonacci sequence and I'm
like oh god I took math lake over a
decade ago I don't know about you but I
see this and I'm like I don't even
remember what the Fibonacci sequence is
so when somebody starts to explain or
corrosion to me by talking about food
not cheesy friends I'm whatever one time
though a friend explained to me
recursion by talk about pictorials I
think everybody really likes factorial
because they have this cute little
exclamation point and if you remember
them more like elementary or middle
school mathematics like that makes a lot
more sense and I really like that
definition of recursion so when somebody
talks about that I feel a lot more like
this a good example
alright next incarnation so
concatenation on the online etymology
dictionary refers to a linking together
to link together a chain like well we
actually use that word correctly in
computer science go up there really any
reason I want to bring up this word of
God cabinet and this is my cat
everything better concat and here's the
recursive cat
infinitely function ok anyway it next
evidence and she ate there once and she
ate from the online etymology dictionary
it comes from instant and it was created
in 1946 and my god that's pretty recent
actually and then I go to Google and I
my brother's intervention and it mean to
represent as or by an instant and their
example is a study of two groups who
seem to instantiate productive aspects
of this this what
as if this wasn't confusing enough in
javascript
Wikipedia when I 3:30 and financial
issue and i actually come across
philosophy and it says that in predicate
logic universal instantiation also known
as you also called universal
specification or universal elimination
and sometimes confused with dictum the
Army is it held rule of inference from a
truth about each member of a class of
individuals to the truth about a
particular individual of that class
flick that kind of makes sense but
basically all catherine hammill rise a
cat and therefore fries animal that's
universal universal instantiation in
philosophy so here I have a class that
have created called mammal and a class
that I've called cat and I thought the
caps prototype 2 mammal and instantiate
a new cat here called Frank at so
basically fried pork at all cats are
mammal and therefore frank at is also a
minimal like cool another good thing
that we have correct in computers like
intention but weirdly the online
etymology dictionary instantiation
actually redirects to instantiate and on
Wikipedia and shit redirects to
negotiation so we only have either the
noun form or the verb form you can't
have both apparently moving onto acronym
here are some acronym I always get
confused CRM and media and just to go
over them again very confusing CRM is a
Customer Relationship Manager kind of
like Salesforce a CMS content management
kind of like WordPress and a CD and is a
content delivery network kind of like
Amazon CloudFront next versus when
you're talking about that please clarify
to me which one you are talking about
are you talking about software as a
service like Salesforce are you talking
about think tactically awesome style
sheets which is the CSS extension
language I don't know but if you don't
tell me that I'm gonna get back to you
about it next to the DOM
there are many kinds of Dom this is
great for da which is a chapel in
Austria this is Dom the indie rock band
and they feed on which is a mountain
located in the out and again we feel
that word
but there are many kinds of Dom but the
damn that we're interested in is the
Document Object Model wikipedia says
that the DOM is a cross-platform in
language independent convention for
representing and interacting with
objects in HTML HTML and XML document
kind of makes sense to me let's keep
hoping for another definition so I
searched Mozilla developers network and
I feel that the DOM is a programming
interface for HTML XML in a 3G document
it provides a structure representation
of the document a tree and it defines
the way that the structure can be
accessed from programs so that they can
change the document structure style and
content
go okay maybe a little bit more sense to
me thank them the best of all they
actually have an illustration of the
tree oh my god that's what it looks like
cool right next is GUI and CLI so I like
he'll likely because if we call it GUI
why can't we call it clean it when I
hear weekly butter cake and then I just
can't work anymore
I also think about greed I'm not sure if
you all know what that is but it's
basically a weird bivalve in the ocean
it's also edible kind of PC little
things but strangely this is actually
are useful gooey duck kind of
counterintuitive and then when I read Li
I read it as clear again and that makes
me think about Paul Klee the painter but
most of us I think really know that
gooey are graphical user interfaces and
they were first introduced in reaction
to the perceived steep learning curve of
command line interfaces or please as I
like to call them which require command
to be typed on the keyboard and lastly I
have Ajax I love the word a jack but
it's really outdated because to even use
of XML I also found recently that date
the jQuery AJAX method has an option to
set a thing to false that means that you
can actually be running as judge
alright in conclusion to hear these
terms like I have no idea what you're
talking about and as soon as you
understand it you just get it because
you just get it it makes it really hard
to explain those terms to somebody else
you kind of have to wait for them to
nudge them until just hits so I know
it's really difficult to explain other
people but I implore you when somebody
asks you to explain a term China this
year like this we're trying to pass the
buck to make somebody else to explain it
because you don't feel like it and try
to preview a little bit more like this
it's so hard to understand and let's
watch this video so we see here
number 12 has just fallen on the ice and
she was like I don't understand what
good is
everyone around me is talking about GUI
they're all talking about going and I
don't know what it means another number
12 is like let me help you I would
explain GUI tu guey it's just the
graphical user interface and other never
told us like I understand thank you
number 12 then we can party together in
the computer science jargon land thanks
so much